bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir et
cinéaste auteur d'un docu-fiction
exceptionnel un événement sur France
Télévisions sur l'affaire d'Outreau le
grand fiasco judiciaire de notre
histoire bonsoir Olivier Ayach Vidal
merci d'être avec nous comment filmer
des vies brisés 20 ans après c'est un
subtil mélange on le verra entre
reconstitution et témoignage votre
co-réalisatrice Agnès pédilie sera là
tout à l'heure dans la deuxième partie
pour en parler on a du temps on est
ensemble pendant une heure pour
commenter l'actualité de ce jeudi 19
janvier et l'actualité ce soir bien
évidemment c'est la réforme des
retraites première grosse grosse
démonstration de force le million de
personnes a été dépassé selon la police
et même très largement selon les
syndicats plus de 2 millions pour
Philippe Martinez les grévistes qui
gagnent la première manche de ce bras de
fer mais quelle sera la suite le
gouvernement est-il prêt à lâcher du
laisse son en débat dans un instant avec
nos invités puis à 20h15 vous le savez
vos deux rendez-vous les cartes blanches
de nos affranchis et le bourbon Express
bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée vous êtes prêts vous me
suivez ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
une marée humaine il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup de monde dans le pays pour dire
non à la réforme des retraites les
chiffres de la police sont tombés il y a
quelques minutes un million 120 000
personnes dans le pays 80 000 dans la
capitale ce sont donc les chiffres du
ministère de l'intérieur ils sont
évidemment différents pour les syndicats
on va faire le point sur cette bataille
des chiffres et cette première très
grosse démonstration de force bonsoir
François Cormier boligeon merci d'être
là vous êtes député renaissance du Cher
en face de vous Thomas porte bonsoir
député la France insoumise de
Seine-Saint-Denis ça tombe bien parce
que vous êtes aussi cheminotes
professions et cheminots cégeistes on a
de vous entendre sur ce qui peut se
passer dans les dans les transports
bonsoir Michel Boga bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous secrétaire confédéral de force
ouvrières et vous l'êtes le monsieur
retraite chez FO enfin bonsoir Stéphane
zoum STEG la bataille de l'opinion elle
est centrale dans ce bras de fer vous
dirigez le département Opinion chez
Ipsos on a besoin de votre éclairage
aussi sur le regard des Français sur
cette réforme mais d'abord les chiffres
je le disais et les premières images le
tout en 200 secondes c'est le chrono
Bianco bien sûr
le regard de Stéphane dure de son
estrade bonsoir Myriam bonsoir messieurs
bonsoir Stéphane alors qu'est-ce que ça
a donné cette manifestation
extraordinaire qui va apparaître dans
cet écran rassurez-vous je ne transforme
pas la chronique en jeu télévision je ne
vous demande pas de chanter le million
peut-être que non mais en fait voilà
c'est le chiffre du jour plus d'un
million de manifestants dans toute la
France et ce n'est pas le chiffre des
organisateurs c'est le chiffre de la
police qui dit un million 120000
personnes dans toute la France la CGT
par le 2 millions de personnes
représentant de FO je crois confirmera
plus de 2 millions aussi selon ses
estimations donc là où c'est frappant
c'est que on attendait pas du tout à une
telle mobilisation en tout cas pas la
police qui disait hier oh là là mais
alors un maximum 750 000 personnes pas
plus finalement on a largement envoyé
cette allée prévisions publiées par BFM
on a largement dépassé ça les images
sont très spectaculaires si vous ne les
avez pas encore vu regardez la place de
la République on ne peut plus mettre un
manifestant de plus pareil grosse
mobilisation dans toutes les grandes
villes de France on a appris
quelques-unes en gros 50000 à Bordeaux à
Nantes à Lille où on dit on n'a jamais
vu autant de monde Marseille est
incapable 150 000 magnifestants sont les
organisateurs 25000 selon la police donc
là je pense que c'est un peu la culture
locale qui brouille un peu les chiffres
bon mais au-delà des grandes villes ce
qui est quand même très très frappant
c'est que la transper périphérique c'est
labellisée c'est-à-dire la France en
dehors justement des grandes villes des
métropoles j'avais l'exemple de Lisieux
que j'avais croisé ce matin où il y
avait dans une ville de 20000 habitants
1700 manifestants presque 10% mais j'ai
trouvé mieux regardez en lisant Le
Télégramme de Brest
oui ça c'est la ville de Morlaix qui
selon Wikipédia compte 15000 habitants
et selon Le Télégramme compte 6000
manifestants donc un tiers de la
population dans la rue on imagine au
niveau de la France ça ferait 25
millions de personnes dans les rues on
en est pas là mais si j'insiste
là-dessus c'est parce que oui la France
périphérique ça ça mit de réservoir au
mouvement des gilets jaunes et ça peut
avoir de l'importance pour la suite du
mouvement si ces gens-là sont mobilisés
donc c'était aussi cette grève alors là
pareil les les chiffres vont du simple
au double notamment chez les enseignants
le ministère nous dit 38,5 les syndicats
75% de taux de grévistes ça c'est pour
école et maternelle mais les mêmes
différences se font entre lycée et puis
collège parfois grosse mobilisation par
exemple
dans certaines raffineries 100% de
mobilisation et puis même chez CGT
énergie maintenant ils ont fait baisser
la production donc il y a eu un coup de
stress pour tout le monde il y a pas eu
de coupure mais ça a rappelé que malgré
tout ça pourrait peut-être être une
manière d'intervenir qu'est-ce que je
peux vous dire bah oui les hommes
politiques on les a pas mis au premier
plan donc je vais pas les mettre non
plus en tête de chronique tout le monde
a dit son petit mot à la télé Mélenchon
Olivier fort marine Tondelier bon celui
qui est quand même le mieux dans les
punchlines à gauche c'est Fabien Roussel
donc on lui laisse rappeler que il y a
pas que les retraites qui inquiètent les
Français on écoute pour beaucoup de
salariés ils ont un salaire hybride
aujourd'hui la moitié pour l'essence
l'autre moitié pour l'électricité et en
plein milieu un président qui vous dit
en plus vous avez bossé deux ans de plus
comment voulez-vous que un moment donné
ça craque pas dans ce pays donc
maintenant ce qu'on attend c'est bien de
sur la suite donc l'Inter syndicale est
réuni pour l'instant on n'a pas encore
la décision qui a été prise parce que
hier voilà mais en tout cas Philippe
Martinez aujourd'hui pouvait dire la
balle n'est plus dans notre camp mais
alors dans quel camp elle est on écoute
le problème il est dans le camp du
gouvernement c'est son projet de loi et
si il est retiré il y aura pas de
mobilisation et on est et on l'a dit on
est prêt et on a des solutions pour
améliorer le système actuel pas le
chambouler et nous faire travailler plus
longtemps notamment bah voilà mes 200
secondes donc je vous laisse débattre et
je surveille les dépêches si la décision
de l’inter syndicale sur la décision de
l'avenir est prise on vous tient au
courant
dès qu'on a cette décision je vais
commencer par le syndicaliste que vous
êtes Michel bogas le million de
manifestants est donc atteint ça c'est
une certitude puisque la police parle un
million 120 000 pas vraiment on peut le
dire à Paris notamment dans quel état
d'esprit vous êtes ce soir vous criez
déjà victoire alors écoutez pour créer
victoire faudra que le gouvernement
retire son projet pour l'instant je n'ai
pas entendu je n'ai pas entendu le dire
qu'il allait retirer effectivement c'est
une grosse grosse mobilisation ça a été
rappelé c'est plus que les chiffres de
la police nous nous avons nos propres
estimations ou je sais que c'est
toujours voilà un sujet que discuté mais
nous sommes nous dans nos propres
calculs à plus de 2300 000 manifestants
à Paris il suffit de regarder la photo
voilà de la place de la République
on se souvient qu'en 95 il y avait moins
du million pour la première grande manif
alors après le pays était complètement à
l'arrêt en 2010 pareil on est on est
dans quoi là dans ce début de bras de
fer écoutez ça fait déjà un moment que
les organisations syndicales vont être
syndicale une interse syndicale
exceptionnelle qui ne s'était pas vu
depuis bien longtemps depuis plus de 12
ans ça fait plus de deux mois que
l'Inter syndicale se réunit et dit au
président de la République et au
gouvernement qu'on est contre la réforme
qu'il veut présenter sur les retraites
le gouvernement a renoncé à passer en
force avec le dans le pdfss dans le
projet de loi de finance de la sécurité
sociale il a dit ok on va se concerter
donc on a eu les concerts par exemple
nous force au voyage on a fait plus de
182 réunions partout en France avec nos
œufs syndicats dans les entreprises pour
justement dire aux salariés tout le mal
qu'on pensait
leur revanche François Cormier
beaudigeon bon vous allez me dire on s'y
attendait ça serait voilà ça serait pas
simple mais là c'est beaucoup quand même
non mais voilà écoutez nous on a
organisé la concertation les syndicats
notre ami nous disaient tout à l'heure
ont organisé la mobilisation pour les
manifestations voilà c'est le ministre
du Travail on connaît que la
mobilisation est importante ce sont ces
mots elle est importante elle est elle
est importante un peu plus d'un million
entre la police et les organisateurs
maintenant les journalistes sont très
bien leur travail on saura le chiffre
d'ici quelques heures j'imagine dans
tous les cas c'est une mobilisation qui
est importante je note comme vous
qu'elle s'est passé de bonnes façons les
forces de l'ordre ont assuré la sécurité
des manifestants et en démocratie c'est
important donc celles dont les forces de
l'ordre et Gérald Darmanin et prenons
effectivement cette mobilisation au
sérieux parce que ça signifie quoi ça
signifie ça veut dire quoi ça signifie
concrètement ça signifie quoi ça veut
dire qu'il faut continuer le dialogue et
convaincre sur l'utilité et la justesse
de cette réforme ça veut dire aussi
comprendre des inquiétudes des Français
personne n'a envie de travailler plus en
réalité pas plus moi que vous et
d'ailleurs je vais vous faire un aveu en
1995 moi aussi j'étais parmi les
manifestants mais depuis la situation
s'est dégradé et donc nous devons
absolument assurer la pérennité de la
retraite par répartition la pédagogie
expliquer est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
bouger sur le fond du texte et nous
avons déjà bougé nous avons déjà à
travers la concertation avancée à
travers l'index seniors les carrières
longues après des discussions avec les
syndicats la première ministre a aussi
bougé après le dialogue avec la majorité
puisque vous avez déjà bougé vous oui
maintenant le minimum retraite donc tout
ça c'est extrêmement important ce sont
des mesures de justice et les Français
le savent donc nous devons continuer à
expliquer parce que c'est le dialogue et
c'est normal en démocratie pourquoi
pourquoi aujourd'hui la retraite par
répartition n'est plus assurée et
pourquoi cette réforme va permettre de
la pérenniser on reviendra sur ce qui
peut encore bouger s'il y a du gramme ou
de ou pas mais ce qui fait des basses et
l'âge ça ça bougera pas c'est sûr non
mais moi je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent que pour assurer la
solidarité intergénérationnelle nous
devons augmenter le nombre de trimestres
cotisés et donc nous faisons quoi à
travers cette réforme nous accélérons la
réforme Touraine qui a été décidée par
la gauche il y a quelques années donc ça
ça me paraît indispensable sur les 64
ans moi je fais partie de ceux qui sont
réservés parce que très honnêtement je
ne souhaite pas qu'une partie de nos
concitoyens soit amenés à travailler 44
ans pour vous parler des carrières
longues là oui vous parlez du recul de
l'âge à 64 pour tous à partir du moment
où nous décidons que le nombre de
trimestres cotisés ça 43 ans pour aller
vite je ne veux pas que certains de nos
concitoyens soient amenés à travailler
44 donc c'est intéressant
sur le reste le fait de devoir accélérer
le fait de devoir travailler plus
longtemps c'est une évidence parce que
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce qu'on
peut entendre parfois les retraites par
répartition n'est plus financée oui on
recule de l'âge légal mais attention à
ceux qui voudraient le dialogue
qui devrait pas travailler 44 sereine
dans un débat on va revenir à
l'atmosphère vous étiez dans les
cortèges dans ma porte je j'imagine pas
loin de la CGT
quoi ce n'est qu'un début continuons le
combat c'est ça l'idée ce soir c'est un
début mais c'est un début qui marque
quand même une première victoire de la
mobilisation sociale les chiffres sont
inédits depuis 1995 plus de 2 millions
de manifestants toutes les organisations
syndicales le disent il y avait une
colère dans un pays qui s'exprimait au
travers des différentes enquêtes
d'opinion enfin j'entends qu'on parle de
pédagogie qu'il faut expliquer aux
françaises aux Français mais ils ont
très bien compris de quoi il s'agit 93%
des actifs ne veulent pas cette réforme
deux tiers des Français ils sont reposés
deux tiers des Français soutiennent les
mobilisations la réponse aujourd'hui qui
a apporté par la rue elle est singlante
c'est retirée ce projet sinon il y aura
d'autres dates de mobilisation parce que
vous parlez
de toi bien sûr c'était plutôt bon
enfant il y avait de colère ça veut pas
dire d'enthousiasme
la colère la colère ça veut pas dire
être violent ça veut dire être déterminé
par des moyens d'action qui sont
déterminés par les organisations
syndicales et qui sont notamment la
grève à faire reculer le gouvernement et
retirer le projet de réforme c'est ça
aujourd'hui vous vous souhaitez quoi on
a entendu Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça c'est le
retrait mais sur la stratégie vous
voulez un mouvement durable qui
s'installe sur le temps là pour donner
des consignes aux organisations
syndicales aux salariées qui sont dans
leur rôle et qui décide des modalités
d'action nous on participera à toutes
les mobilisations qui seront mises à
l'agenda par l'intercyndical et il faut
se féliciter qu'il y a une intersey
syndicale et qui soit unie première fois
depuis 2010 c'est un élément qui
déterminant dans la mobilisation des
salariés il y a une date qui va arriver
samedi à l'appel des organisations de
jeunesse où j'appelle à participer mais
la réponse véritablement aujourd'hui
elle est enfin deux millions de
personnes ils sont mesurer vous avez
juste pour terminer vous avez évoqué des
sous-préfectures et des préfectures non
mes parents ils sont originaires du
Sud-Ouest ils habitent à Agen il y avait
9000 personnes à Agen sur une ville de
30 000 habitants là aussi jamais vu
depuis 95 donc il y a un rejet massif de
cette réforme donc le gouvernement doit
l'entendre et la seule issue c'est le
retrait alors justement c'est
intéressant de savoir et on va parler de
l'opinion avec vous Stéphane zumsteak
dans un instant qui était dans les
cortèges la composition de ces cortèges
c'est aussi un très très bon marqueur de
l'opposition alors est-ce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de salariés du privé notamment
est-ce que la jeunesse était dans la rue
reportage dans la capitale avec Clément
Perrot
en tête du cortège parisien juste
derrière les leaders syndicaux les
valeurs sûres des grandes mobilisations
fonction publique cheminots personnels
de santé sont fidèle au poste je suis
conducteur de train TGV je me vois pas
conduire un train à plus de 60 ans je
suis aide-soignant et on veut pas partir
à 64 ou 65 ans on veut partir plus tôt
déjà vu les conditions de travail qu'on
a qui sont difficiles j'ai 56 ans et je
suis enseignante et ça fait 3 ans je
suis enseignante je pourrais partir dans
deux ans puisque j'ai un statut
particulier et là tout est remis en
cause voilà pourquoi je suis là
aujourd'hui
il faut entrer dans les entrailles du
cortège pour les trouver mais ils sont
là aussi les salariés du privé des
carrières souvent très différentes mais
un refus commun de retarder lors du
départ je travaille dans l'aéronautique
j'ai safran
j'ai je vais avoir 57 ans et ça risque
de me faire faire 15 mois de plus alors
que j'ai commencé à travailler à 17 ans
et que j'ai fait 3538
44 ans et je suis hôtesse de l'air je
suis aujourd'hui avec mes collègues pour
pouvoir défendre notre caisse de
retraite de retraite autonome la CRPN
d'accès vidéo et la réforme elle me
plaît pas du tout parce qu'elle me
rajoute du temps de travail et moi je
préfère partir la retraite plus tôt
parce que j'ai envie de profiter tout
simplement un peu de ma vie quoi je suis
ingénieur j'ai 54 ans j'ai jamais fait
grève de ma vie sur la première fois et
je risque de perdre deux ans sur mon âge
de retraite et je suis vraiment en
colère
présent aussi par petit groupe les
lycéens et les étudiants mobilisés déjà
pour la retraite mais pas seulement
je suis étudiante et je manifeste contre
la réforme de retraite mais aussi plus
généralement pour dire que dans la
jeunesse il y a une précarité une
inquiétude pour l'avenir au niveau de la
crise écologique etc et qu'on pense que
la priorité c'est pas une réforme une
énième référence sociale on est là
aujourd'hui pour représenter les
étudiants précaires pour représenter les
travailleurs qui se battent au quotidien
qui qui gagnent des salaires de merde en
décembre et qui montre retrouver à 64 67
70 ans à trimer encore et ne pas avoir
droit à la retraite quoi
les manifestants s'entendent sur un
point se rassemblement ne sera pas le
dernier c'est une course de fond qui les
attend
Stéphane zums c'était quand on voit
l'éventail de grévistes et de manifester
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que toutes
les catégories d'actifs s'opposent à
cette réforme est-ce qu'on peut le dire
les Français s'opposent majoritairement
à ce projet de réforme en gros ça dépend
des enquêtes de pignons et des moments
ils sont réalisés mais il y a plus de 6
français sur sur 10 quel que soit leur
âge quel que soit leur
santé en
casyptosés les actifs encore plus que la
moyenne des Français c'est vrai ce que
l'on voit quand même dans le cortège
dans ces cortèges c'est que malgré tout
parce que c'est une tradition française
c'est pas une remise en cause de
l'efficacité ou de la légitimité de ces
mouvements sociaux il y aura toujours
plus parce que nous sommes en France et
c'est comme ça plus de représentants des
grandes entreprises publiques de
l'énergie et des transports que de
salariés du secteur privé qui ont moins
l'habitude en tout cas qui ont pas la
même culture de la mobilisation et de la
manifestation mais ce n'est pas une
remise en cause de de
l'ampleur de ce mouvement aujourd'hui ce
que l'on constate vraiment c'est que les
Français sont arc-boutés aujourd'hui
dans le refus du passage de 62 du
décalage du report de 62 à 64 ans de
légal du départ à la retraite c'est
vraiment ce qui la mesure qui
cristalline cette opposition ce mot de
résignation on entend beaucoup notamment
dans la bouche de la majorité en disant
avec l'hyper crise dans lequel on est
le contexte d'inflation les Français
n'iront pas jusqu'à véritablement
faire le bras de fer jusqu'au bout ça ça
on le sent pas dans les enquêtes alors
ce que l'on sent dans les enquêtes c'est
que au-delà de l'opposition des Français
à cette réforme et donc leur soutien et
la mobilisation d'aujourd'hui et
éventuellement ou celle qui pourrait se
développer dans les jours qui viennent
il y a quand même le sentiment qu'il
faudra bien un jour réformer le système
de retraite ça ne signifie pas
pour autant qu'ils adhèrent au projet
présenté par par le gouvernement
pourquoi pour deux raisons parce que
d'une part contenu du contexte que vous
évoquiez contexte économique contexte
international très anxiogène considère
c'est le très mauvais moment il y a
jamais de bons moments pour réformer les
retraites mais c'est vraiment pas le
moment aujourd'hui c'est un peu ce qui
nous dit ce qui nous disent dans les
enquêtes il y a aussi un refus pour
l'instant en tout cas de l'ampleur pour
les opposants de la brutalité des
mesures qui ont été proposées et ça ça
marque l'opinion qui reste qui reste
assez déterminé dans ce soutien
maintenant il y a des exemples il y a
l'exemple de 95 un exemple de réussite
de réussite de d'un mouvement social
mais il y a aussi d'autres exemples ou
quelque part le soutien des français
d'opinion publique à l'égard des
personnes qui se mobilisaient et qui
pouvaient éventuellement à un moment
donné empêcher des trains de de rouler
parce qu'ils avaient décidé de faire la
grève c'était pas des blocages mais
c'était quand même malgré tout des
conséquences néfastes sur la vie
quotidienne ces choses-là peuvent aussi
jouer un rôle est-ce que vous diriez
aujourd'hui que les contextes les
conditions sont réunies pour une
explosion sociale dans le pays ou pas
parce que il arrive dans un moment
particulier
nous avons dans notre pays des gens qui
n'ont pas de bien qui n'ont pas de
capital qui n'ont pas de patrimoine et
donc si nous ne sauvegardons pas la
retraite par répartition ils n'auront
pas de quoi vivre après avoir travaillé
c'est ça la réalité moi je viens de ce
milieu modeste donc je le connais donc
quand on a pas d'argent quand on a pas
de patrimoine on a besoin d'avoir une
retraite par répartition pour vivre à la
fin de sa vie active
et ce système est aujourd'hui n'est plus
financé si nous ne faisons rien il sera
en déficit on aura accumulé 150
milliards de déficit en disant et donc
ça ça n'est pas possible parce que ça
veut dire que nous transmettons une
dette à nos enfants vous voulez faire ça
vous moi je ne veux pas transmettre à
mes enfants je ne veux pas transmettre à
mes enfants ces dettes et moi je veux
garder un système juste de solidarité
intergénérationnelle telle qu'il a été
construit après-guerre c'est-à-dire que
les actifs financent les pensions des
retraités parce que ça ça crée de nation
ça fait de la nation ça fait que on a
cette solidarité entre nous et donc il
faut absolument le garder et donc moi je
suis prêt à cotiser davantage de
trimestre pour permettre de payer des
retraits des anciens pour permettre
d'augmenter la retraite minimum j'ai
dans ma circonscription vous savez dans
le Cher des gens qui viennent me voir là
je suis dans mes cérémonies de vœux et
chaque année je fais ça moi dans des
dizaines de communes j'ai des gens des
femmes qui viennent me voir elles vivent
avec 400 500 600 euros elle ne se soigne
plus elle ne se nourrissent plus elle
paye à peine leur logement ça c'est
injuste et donc nous allons mettre la
retraite minimum à 1200 euros ça c'est
une mesure de justice sociale importante
alors le syndicaliste j'aimerais vous
entendre et ensuite on va tout de suite
se rendre à l'intérieur syndical parce
que je crois qu'il y a une date ça y est
qui a été on va laisser on va laisser
notre porteur sur le terrain de nous
l'annoncer dans moins d'une minute
Michel bogaz la dimension de justice je
crois déjà que on n'a pas la même
lecture du rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites et le
meilleur système qui puisse exister au
monde c'est bien le système par
répartition et notre retraite n'est pas
en danger il faut arrêter de faire peur
te dire au retraités actuel qu'on va
baisser leurs pensions et de dire aux
jeunes qui n'auront pas de retraite
de moins en moins de cotisants
plus de retraités
ne participent plus à l'effort national
pour préserver notre justice sociale
justement peut-être qu'il faut
rééquilibrer les choses dans ce sens-là
il y a d'autres solutions on a proposé
au gouvernement d'autres solutions on
prend les choses à l'envers travaillons
sur l'emploi dans ce pays regardons
comment justement on peut garder les les
travailleurs seniors comme on les
appelle en emploi il y a des solutions
il y a des propositions dans cette
réforme notamment l'index
10 points 10 points 10 points 10 points
de plus dans l'emploi des seniors c'est
50 milliards ça veut dire que ça
équilibre le régime travaillons déjà sur
l'emploi contraignant les entreprises à
garder les seniors au lieu de les
licenciers et on verra que ça ira mieux
sauf que c'est pas le choix qui a fait
le gouvernement le gouvernement a fait
le choix de punir les salariés et de
punir les retraités justement c'est sur
la question de l'emploi que nous
travaillons plus depuis 5 ans nous avons
un des taux de chômage les plus bas nous
sommes à 7% de chômage
voilà ce que vous créez le taux de
chômage des jeunes est au plus bas et le
taux d'emploi des seniors et plus élevé
qu'il ne l'était justement grâce à la
réforme Touraine on a multiplié je crois
par deux le taux d'emploi des seniors
donc c'est précisément ce que nous
sommes en train de faire pour permettre
que l'emploi paye les retraites c'est ça
l'équilibre juste François Cormier
religion je vous avais promis on va se
rendre tout de suite devant le siège de
solidaire c'est là que l'Inter syndicale
s'est réuni ce soir depuis 19h bonsoir
Stéphanie Despierre le front syndical a
tenu est-ce qu'une nouvelle date de
mobilisation est déjà lancée
oui l'unité à payer aujourd'hui alors
les syndicats veulent continuer ils
viennent de se mettre d'accord sur une
nouvelle date de mobilisation ce sera
donc le 31 janvier ils étaient réunis
depuis environ à 18h ici au siège de
solidaire après cette journée à deux
mobilisation plutôt à réussir un million
120000 manifestants dans toute la France
selon ministère de l'Intérieur deux
millions selon à la CGT alors vous le
voyez on attend les déclarations des
délégués syndicaux d'une minute à
l'autre alors il n'y avait pas les
figures Philippe Martinez pour la CGT ou
Laurent Berger pour la CFDT mais il y
avait autour de la table les numéros 2
les numéros 3 mais tout c'était là
l'unité syndicale qui qui dure depuis
quelques semaines était encore là et
puis autour de la table il y avait
également les mouvements lycéens et les
syndicats étudiants donc ils se sont
tous mis d'accord pour une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation le 31 janvier
c'est beaucoup Stéphanie Despierre le 31
janvier je viens de regarder sur mon
calendrier c'est donc en semaine c'est
un mardi c'est dans 10 jours
Pacifique deux contestations d'un projet
de loi alors il y a quelque chose que
regarde le président de la République de
très très près il s'est exprimé on va
l'entendre tout à l'heure depuis
Barcelone il y a un instant c'est c'est
ce qu'on appelle dans le gouvernement le
syndrome des des raffineries Stéphane
homsg on voit que pour l'instant les
menaces sur les élus il y a un peu
rétropédalage à la CGT que la CGT
énergie certes la production
d'électricité diminue mais pour
l'instant il n'y a pas d'effet à la
pompe sur le blocage des raffineries il
existe dans la société ce syndrome là
est-ce que ça peut se transformer en un
mouvement un peu plus autonome avec de
la radicalisation et des blocages dans
la vie quotidienne des Français oui
probablement
spécialiste des organisations syndicales
et des mouvements sociaux mais bien
évidemment que on a vu très récemment il
y a encore quelques jours enfin ou
quelques semaines des mouvements qui
n'avaient pas été encadrés par les
organisations syndicales je pense
notamment à la grève des contrôleurs de
trains le weekend de Noël qui
j'accepte beaucoup moins facilement
qu'auparavant ce qui est intéressant ce
soir c'est que vous avez la casquette
CGT mais vous avez aussi la casquette
d'élus vous condamnez ce qu'a dit la CGT
énergie une partie d'entre elles vous
comptez pas sûrement pour condamner les
organisations syndicales et les mots
d'ordre des responsables syndicaux
on va venir vous chercher
chercher
l'électricité vous ne condamnez pas non
je la pression sur un parlementaire vous
ne condamnez pas bah écoutez écoutez
vous étiez membre d'une majorité vous
avez envoyé des flics tabassés des
manifestants et c'est vous qui allez
faire c'est vous qui allez me faire des
leçons aujourd'hui le responsabilités
la CGT énergie n'a dit la redit il y a
encore aujourd'hui qui n'aurait pas de
coupure et qui aurait simplement des
reprises en main de la production
mais moi je veux dire je veux dire une
chose vous parlez aujourd'hui de
radicalité mais les gens qui pourrissent
la vie aujourd'hui de la population
française c'est le gouvernement avec ce
projet de réforme évidemment qu'il va y
avoir certainement une montée en force
mobilisation bien sûr la radicalisation
du mouvement mais qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire la radicalité ça veut dire avoir un
mouvement large unitaire qui soit sur la
durée pour faire plier le gouvernement
si la radicalité assumait c'est le
blocage du pays pendant par rapport à la
violence là c'est une mesure qui fait
qu'on est fort sur ce qu'on propose et
qu'on est déterminé à faire grève c'est
pas un mot d'ordre violent la radicalité
dans les idées politiques par exemple
c'est remettre en cause le système du
capitalisme moi je me pose quand même
militaire mais c'est pas un militaire
violent attends je veux juste terminer
sur une chose parce que oui s'il faut
que le pays soit à l'arrêt pendant
plusieurs jours plusieurs semaines pour
que le projet de réforme soit retiré
mais il faudra qu'il soit à l'arrêt et
c'est les salariés qui vont décider et
nous on soutiendra toutes les
mobilisations mais quand j'entends
écouter
permettez-moi juste cette question si ce
projet de loi est voté qu'est-ce que
vous faites qui qui l'emporte chez vous
le c'est génétisme ou le député pour
respecterez le vote de la représentation
nationale c'est une question que je vous
pose mais j'ai toujours respecté la
représentation nationale simplement il
vous a pas échappé que quand tu ne loi
évo-telle peut aussi être abrogée avec
des mobilisations on l'a vu avec le CPE
donc les mobilisations et on en est pas
encore là mais je crois que le
gouvernement est en difficulté quand on
voit les chiffres laissez-moi juste
terminer là-dessus quand on voit les
chiffres d'aujourd'hui et vous venez
encore ici nous expliquer que il y aura
pas de système de retraite pour les
jeunes générations que c'est en danger
on parle de 12 milliards dans un pays où
vous versez quasiment 160 milliards
d'aide aux entreprises où on a des
dividendes à hauteur de 80 milliards qui
ne sont pas taxés pour financer le
système de solidarité de retraite il y a
de l'argent partout dans ce pays et on
met un contribution le plus fragile et
cette réforme elle va sacrifier déjà
alors déjà terminé
c'est une
pauvreté vous êtes un gouvernement ultra
riche arrêtez avec ça de millionnaire
dans ce gouvernement vous voyez pas des
leçons nous nous voulons le plein emploi
nous voulons que les gens de leur
travail c'est ce que nous voulons et
c'est ce sur que nous travaillons
il sera plus facile de financer des
retraites par répartition c'est ça que
nous voulons ça c'est la justice et donc
moi je veux comme le dit Monsieur
bogasse des manifestations qui soient
pacifiques constructives des syndicats
mais je veux aussi un débat serein dans
l'hémicycle avec la présentation
nationale et du démocratiquement vous
comme moi et un débat démocratique qui
permette le vote d'une loi et cette loi
là ça ne sera pas de l'injustice ça sera
le contraire ça sera assuré la retraite
par répartition
on va s'arrêter là je rappelle la date
du 31 janvier qui a été annoncé c'est
dans une dizaine de jours le projet de
loi est présenté lundi prochain c'est le
23 d'ailleurs il doit y avoir aussi
quelques mouvements de mobilisation ce
jour-là précisément peut-être pour clore
ce débat le
sondeur que vous êtes Stéphane zumsteg
est-ce que la représentation nationale a
un effet sur sur ce bras de fer est-ce
que si le vote a lieu parce qu'on
imagine que ça va se faire
l'opinion peut soutenir plutôt
l'assemblée que que la rue ou pas du
tout là quand je reviens à ce sentiment
qu'il faudra bien un jour en passer par
là pas forcément la réforme dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui évidemment mais s'il
y a un vote ce ça aura forcément un
élément démobilisateur sur une partie
sur une partie seulement évidemment des
Français mais ça peut aussi susciter une
exaspération encore plus forte de la
part des opposants donc c'est à la fois
un facteur d'apaisement pour certains et
un facteur de directive
pardon pour les autres donc je réponds
pas vraiment à votre question parce que
on ne sait pas ce qui pourra se passer
ça jouera dans les deux sens l'opinion
publique pour l'instant est je le répète
très très énervé ce projet le bras de
fer il est là il est dur et il ne fait
que commencer merci à vous messieurs on
va évidemment continuer à en parler
longtemps je retiens quand même qu'il y
a des ouvertures sur le fond possible
notamment sur la question des 44 ans de
cotisations vous restez avec moi Olivier
Ayach Vidal dans une dizaine de minutes
les parties pris de nous affranchis vous
les voyez en coulisses ce soir que
hiridelle revient sur le coup de gueule
des Nations Unies à Davos contre le
cynisme des géants du pétrole le regard
de Mario Stasi de la lycra sur les
pseudos excuses de Dieudonné et le
bourbon express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée mais d'abord on va se
replonger dans le dossier ou trop grâce
à vous et à votre co-réalisatrice Agnès
speedoni qui va nous rejoindre les deux
premiers épisodes de votre docu-fiction
ont été un gros succès sur France 2
mardi soir les deux suivants sont
diffusés et bien lundi prochain le parti
pris de réalisation est absolument
remarquable la Tour du Renard a été
entièrement reconstituée à Outreau et
puis les acquitter les acquitter
confrontés à leur double fictif on
regarde d'abord ce que ça donne dans
l'invitation de Diane karcher
si on vous invite Agnès pizini et Olivia
age Vidal c'est pour parler de votre
documentaire fiction consacré à
l'affaire d'Outreau diffusé sur France 2
Agnès pizini vous venez du documentaire
tandis qu'Olivia ayajidal vous êtes
cinéaste de vision pour arriver à cet
objet télévisuel non
identifié quatre épisodes de 52 minutes
ou se mêlent images d'archives
reconstitution et interview des
protagonistes de cette affaire
souvenez-vous c'était en l'an 2000
nouvelle affaire dans le Nord
particulièrement glaçante quatre enfants
d'une même famille
âgée de 7 à 11 ans était prostituée par
leurs parents pour payer les courses en
quelque sorte ça se passe à Outreau à la
cité du renard quatre frères racontent
les viols commis par leurs parents
Myriam Badaoui et Thierry Delay et puis
au fur et à mesure des auditions
enchaînent les dénonciations la machine
s'emballe 17 personnes accusées des amis
des voisins deux procès ont lieu en 2004
et 2005 je joue le méga de garçons
c'est très pénible à dire
ça a commencé en 95 mais je dépasse tous
les gens qui sont ici les accusés ils
ont aussi violé les enfants malgré les
déclarations de Myriam Badaoui seul 4
personnes sont finalement reconnues
coupables elle est son mari ainsi qu'un
couple d'amis très autre sont acquittés
certaines après avoir passé plusieurs
années en prison l'Assemblée nationale
elle-même a enquêter sur ce fiasco
judiciaire c'était en 2006 la première
commission d'enquête parlementaire
diffusée en direct et c'était sur LCP
les larmes la colère le malaise pendant
plus de 9 heures les innocentés
d'outeront raconté leur calvaire devant
les parlementaires sidérés qu'est-ce qui
me reste maintenant
un boulot de salarié
et trois enfants
trois enfants détruits
dans ce documentaire fiction vous
revenez sur les faits et vous donner la
parole à 6 des protagonistes tout au
long de la série il traverse la fiction
pour apporter leur réalité comme ici
Jonathan delay l'un des quatre frères à
l'origine des dénonciations
là c'est moi Jonathan 6 ans de 1000 à
l'époque des faits
la façon comment on vivait à la maison
faisait qu'on
grandissait très vite mais aujourd'hui
plus de 20 ans après et alors que la
justice a tranché sur l'affaire
d'Outreau nous vous posons la question
qu'apportez vous de nouveau sur ce
désastre judiciaire qui a déjà tant fait
parler
bonsoir Agnès pidani merci d'être là
c'est un travail colossal que vous avez
mené tous les deux vous êtes plongé dans
ce dans ce gros gros dossier
d'instruction de 38 hommes 18 mois
d'écriture et des décors plus vrac
nature constitués on va en parler il y a
de l'archive il y a du témoignage c'est
pour leur redonner un espace de paix à
ses acquittés que vous avez voulu faire
ce projet quel était votre objectif on a
tellement écrit déjà sur sur
objectif de revenir sur cette affaire 20
ans plus tard avec du recul pour essayer
d'en tirer des enseignements en tirer à
nouveau des enseignements et puis
ensuite effectivement apporter à des
témoignages à travers une fiction mais
c'est vrai que on a été bouleversé par
on a rencontrant par par leur parcours
parce qu'il aurait été arrivé et on
avait aussi envie de leur rendre justice
alors il y a acquitté qui témoignent qui
se regardent c'est ça qui est vraiment
très intéressant dans le dispositif
Daniel Legrand Alain Marie Cau Thierry
dose et l'abbévielle Dominique viel
d'abord comment vous avez fait pour les
convaincre parce que vous parlez c'est
revivre leur cauchemars ouais et
effectivement ça a été ça a été
compliqué on avait la chance de pouvoir
d'être accompagné d'un journaliste belge
qui avait fait leurs connaissances au
moment de la faire et qu'il avait été le
premier à remettre en cause l'idée du
réseau pédophilie donc donc il avait il
avait un lien privilégié avec eux donc
ce qui a fait que ils ont accepté de au
moins ouvrir leurs portes là où ils
l'ont gardé fermé pour tant d'autres
journalistes et puis après c'est un long
travail de de dialogue de mise en
confiance
voilà et de leur faire comprendre parce
que ce que je leur ai expliqué c'est que
moi je sais ce que je viens chercher
chercher chez vous par contre il faut
que vous trouviez un intérêt aussi à
cette expérience il faut que vous en
tiriez quelque chose et voilà et je
crois que c'est ça qui est absolument
incroyable dans le film c'est qu'il y a
un effet cathartique c'est complètement
nouveau cette façon de mettre les codes
du cinéma dans le dans le documentaire
mais vous empruntez aussi au théâtre
avec ses reconstitutions et les
acquitter regarde les acteurs jouer leur
double et la ressemblance est incroyable
parce que les acteurs c'est exactement
eux 20 ans il y a 20 ans et c'est et
c'est ce parti pris voilà de réalisation
qui a eu l'idée c'est vraiment génial ça
ça marche vraiment en fait moi j'étais
sollicité Agnès à travailler beaucoup
sur le dossier en amont etc pour essayer
de vraiment commencer à décortiquer les
choses et moi j'étais surtout sollicité
par rapport à ça c'est à dire parce
qu'il y avait une ambition de France 2
français vision d'essayer de faire de ce
dock déjà aussi un événement de revenir
dessus et puis de
présenter peut-être enfin d'être proposé
une nouvelle narration et je pense que
c'était c'était donc l'objectif
d'essayer de réfléchir à au code et
c'est vrai que j'avais aussi envie de
mélanger par rapport certaines
expériences que j'avais pu faire du
théâtre des voilà des enfin du théâtre
du cinéma et essayer de voir comment ça
tout ça pouvait se mélanger mais il faut
dire que le fond la forme plutôt est au
service vraiment du fond c'est à dire
que cette affaire c'est une affaire qui
mêle il faut expliquer que tout ce qui
est prononcé dans le film est extrait
des PV et que tout est vrai absolument
en fait c'est pas l'idée elle est partie
du fait que en décortiquant ce dossier
on s'est rendu compte que le dossier
finalement du dossier n'essaie une
fiction une histoire et donc tout
l'enjeu c'était d'arriver à le mettre en
scène à la montrer mais en étant hyper
sérieux parce que parce qu'on n'a pas
droit à l'erreur sur ce type d'affaires
il y en a déjà eu assez et donc et donc
tout ce qui
[Musique]
et c'est un enfant à l'époque des faits
il y a une fragilité encore aujourd'hui
absolument Jonathan il a été il a été
voilà enthousiaste par ce projet il y a
participé à vie activement il a
participé aussi à la fiction voilà
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je pense que lui
pour le coup c'est compliqué de se
reconstruire
néanmoins il est dans le dans un combat
qui est la défense des enfants abusés
victimes d'agression sexuelle et de viol
et il est complètement légitime dans ce
combat là mais je pense que en fait
Jonathan il est il est il a du mal
peut-être à reconnaître que il est
victime mais qu'il y a aussi d'autres
victimes dans cette affaire voilà le
grand absent c'est le juge Burgaud
on le voit à travers largement les
extraits de la commission parlementaire
donc c'était c'était un peu ça mais
Agnès c'était allé voir
c'est pas mal de temps à discuter
[Musique]
le moment où les policiers recueillent
la parole des enfants avec des acteurs
et qui désignent avec des petites photos
sur une feuille de papier des gens
innocents
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui qui sont faites notamment
dans les commissions d'enquête sur
l'inceste sur les violences
intrafamilales vous avez forcément
entendu parler du juge Edouard Durand
qui est un juge des enfants et qui dit
aujourd'hui l'effet d'Outreau a
contribué à étouffer la parole des
enfants absolument qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez oui c'est complètement vrai et
c'est et en fait c'est c'est tout le
problème de cette affaire en fait c'est
que après ça on a considéré que les
enfants étaient potentiellement Tous des
menteurs et c'est une catastrophe et je
crois que ce film ce film pour la
première fois donne la parole à toutes
les victimes de cette affaire et pose la
question du recueil de la parole parce
que c'est ce qu'on voit dans le bureau
des policiers aujourd'hui ça ne se passe
plus du tout comme ça là les enfants
sont Inter au milieu du commissariat il
n'y a pas de psy à côté enfin voilà ça a
évolué ensuite mais cette affaire a fait
énormément de mal en effet à l'enfance
abusé pour bien comprendre le dispositif
pour ceux qui n'ont pas vu les deux
premiers volets mais ils sont évidemment
en replay on va regarder un extrait où
Daniel Legrand l'un des acquittéros
rencontre son double
je m'appelle Daniel Legrand j'ai 40 ans
je suis perdu
et j'ai passé 30 mois d'aller barreaux
pour la fin du trou
moi aussi j'allais pas jouer sur les
terrains de football en club j'allais
tout de suite jouer dans les champs
derrière chez moi j'ai passé mon temps à
ça j'étais un sportif accompli
salut tu vas bien ça va ça va enchanté
enchanté Daniel Maceo
la fin du trou ça a l'air vécu
quel âge
a 20 ans en prison pour la faire du trou
et moi je rêvais de football c'était ma
vie quoi puis là où trouver dans ma vie
à 20 ans
quand je parlais de catharsis cette
intention de réalisation c'est vraiment
la signature de ces de ces séries de
docu-fiction comment ils l'ont vécu de
parler comme ça quelque part de
transmettre leur propre histoire pour
peut-être mieux la comprendre aussi je
crois que d'abord ils l'ont vécu à
travers les interviews qui ont été faits
en amont et puis ensuite donc il y avait
une mise en confiance et ensuite je
crois que ils ont été assez je veux dire
intéressés par le ce dispositif pour
pouvoir s'approprier à nouveau cette
histoire à travers des séquences dans
lesquelles ils allaient dans lequel ils
avaient intervenir donc en fait ce qui
est important aussi c'est au-delà du mot
du tournage ce qui est plus important
c'est l'impact que le film peut avoir
maintenant sur leur vie je pense que il
y a eu des retours qui sont vraiment
très positifs j'espère que ça le sera
également pour toutes les victimes même
pour Jonathan évidemment mais c'est vrai
que les les
qu'on a eu que ça soit de
François-Xavier maréco que ce soit de
voilà de Thierry etc de Daniel Legrand
voilà c'est quelque chose qui qui leur
rapporte qui leur fait du bien quoi
merci beaucoup de l'investigation de la
recherche approfondie de la psychologie
et un parti pris quasiment
cinématographique voilà ça donne cette
magnifique série de documentaires
fictions c'est pas vraiment un ovni mais
en même temps voilà il y a des il y a
des nouveautés de réalisation c'est
formidable et donc le prochain séquence
est mardi c'est ça sur sur France 2 vous
restez avec moi tous les deux parce que
c'est l'heure d'accueillir à des parties
primes nos affranchis leur carte blanche
je suis sur vos vont vous faire réagir
ils sont où nos affranchis toujours pas
là on les fait rentrer en studio ou pas
ce soir je vais je vais vous dire qu'ils
sont et bien il y a Chloé Ridel de
l'Institut Rousseau qui arrive et qui va
nous parler Chloé de ce qui s'est passé
à adavos notamment contre les pétroliers
et puis Mario Stasi on en parlait
président de la lycra vous vouliez
revenir ce soir sur le mea culpa quelque
peu suspects de de Dieudonné mais on va
commencer avec le bourbon Express comme
chaque soir qui nous est racontée par
Elsa mondingaval histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée elle traite des retraites à
nouveau oui je vais vous raconter ce
soir l'histoire d'un match un match qui
va se jouer ici à l'Assemblée nationale
entre les partisans et les opposants à
la réforme des retraites ce match il va
pas durer 90 minutes il va durer 20
jours et vous allez me dire à la fin on
va savoir qui va gagner et bien non au
bout de 20 jours pas en plus l'arbitre
va siffler la fin du match il y aura pas
de prolongation possible il va prendre
le ballon le transmettre à d'autres
équipes dans un autre stade le Sénat et
oui Myriam peut-être tu auras pas de
vote sur la réforme des retraites en
tout cas en première lecture ici à
l'Assemblée pourquoi on l'a déjà évoqué
ici parce que le gouvernement a choisi
de passer par un projet de loi de
finance rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale et le gouvernement s'impose et
impose aux oppositions donc des délais
très contraintes 50 jours en tout 20
jours ici en première lecture fin du
chrono le vendredi 17 février à minuit
donc ça veut dire qu'il peut ne pas y
avoir de vote à l'assemblée fausse
figurer les choses en première lecture
ça va surprendre beaucoup beaucoup de de
citoyens si c'est si c'est le cas on
imagine que chacun va se renvoyer la
faute exactement c'est un peu l'argument
de C'est pas moi c'est l'autre est-ce
qu'on peut imaginer que le vendredi 17
au soir on arrête sans vote à
l'assemblée cette réforme des retraites
évidemment c'est ce que nous voulons pas
il va y avoir plus de 20 jours de débats
ici à l'Assemblée nationale pour pouvoir
projet contre projet éclairer les
Français sur la réforme de retraite que
nous nous portons et puis les
oppositions pourront se positionner par
rapport à cela après si la stratégie qui
est maintenue de 100 1150 000
amendements évidemment que nous n'aurons
pas le temps d'aller dans discuter et
donc ça veut dire que au bout de 20
jours parce que c'est la loi cette
organisé comme cela nous obligera et
effectivement à transmettre le texte en
l'état au Sénat nous espérons nous qu'à
chaque fois chaque travail au Sénat et à
national donne lieu à un vote c'est les
oppositions qui choisiront vous l'avez
entendu Myriam s'il n'y a pas de vote ce
sera à cause de l'obstruction des
insoumis c'est l'élément de langage du
gouvernement et de la majorité qui garde
en mémoire bien la précédente réforme
des retraites en 2020 sous Édouard
Philippe alors on est allé voir
l'insoumi Eric Coquerel on lui a demandé
est-ce que son groupe gardera la même
stratégie en 2020 vous étiez 17 vous
aviez déposé quasiment 1000 amendements
par député vous êtes 74 il y en aura 74
000 dans l'hémicycle lors de l'examen on
verra le nombre exact en tout cas il y
en aura suffisamment pour faire en sorte
à la fois d'animer le débat parce que
c'est bien normal mais aussi de faire en
sorte que le débat dure le plus
longtemps possible pour faire en sorte
que la mobilisation puisse grossir
est-ce que cette stratégie elle peut
être
et si le 17 février à minuit le
gouvernement dit bah écoutez c'est à
cause de ces irresponsables d'insoumis
qu'on déposé des dizaines de milliers
d'amendements que le débat il a pas pu
se faire allez on envoie au Sénat vous
savez je pense que les les gens ne
confondent pas les pyromades et les
pompiers gouvernement parce qu'il est en
réalité très peu sûr d'être majoritaire
veut éventuellement se donner le moyen
de pavoter donc c'est à eux qu'il faut
poser cette question c'est eux qui sont
irresponsables de jouer ainsi avec la
démocratie les insoumis veulent donc
faire durer le débat mais ils veulent
aussi débattre de certains articles
importants comme celui qui va porter sur
l'âge légal qu'il faut aussi quand même
avancer et ça aussi leur partenaire de
la nuque bah il le rappelle qu'il
faudrait quand même débattre de
certaines mesures quand on les écoute
elles aiment on a l'impression
finalement c'est pas de vote ça
arrangerait tout le monde non bah oui on
peut avoir cette impression là ça évite
aux député de la majorité un vote
franchement impopulaire à gauche on
pourra dénoncer deux concerts la
brutalité du gouvernement à droite on
affichera pas trop les divisions ça
pourrait ranger tout le monde sauf que
Myriam pour bien comprendre
[Rires]
mais cette antisionisme outrancier n'est
pas la seule manière de corroder les
valeurs et principes républicains il en
existe d'autres plus pernicieuses qui
profitent de l'hospitalité des plateaux
télé ou de certaines revues et se
manifestent sous la forme de vision
fantasmagorique les musulmans se foutent
de la République ils agressent les
Français de souche de généralisation de
généralisation abusive ou de propos
réducteurs de façon de faire de façon de
faire mais dans les deux cas c'est
l'universalisme qui trinque d'ailleurs
ce qui attaque l'universalisme le font
souvent au nom de l'antiracisme il est
vrai Myriam critiquer l'universalisme
républicain est devenu un sport à la
mode il consiste à mettre en cause cette
philosophie politique qui offre à chacun
la possibilité d'être considéré au sein
de la cité comme un individu libre
égal aux autres endroits et en dignité
et non comme le membre d'une communauté
race religion sexe ou couleur de peau
par exemple lorsque l'acteur est
réalisateur Jean-Pascal Z a dit tout
simplement noir explique dans les
colonnes du Monde que l'universalisme
arrange bien du monde lorsqu’il prête à
la République un aveuglement aux
couleurs qui permet je cite de nier
certaines réalités en dénonçant la
réalité sociale ou le racisme et la
discrimination persiste scandaleusement
il dirige ses coûts qui le veuillent ou
non contre le seul projet politique
d'émancipation en laissant entendre que
l'universalisme ne serait qu'un paravent
hypocrite il répond l'idée d'un discours
antiraciste de pacotille et d'une
république qui se complérait dans
l'inaction de la à affirmer que le
combat contre le racisme ne peut être
compris que par les seules discriminés
il n'y a qu'un pas l'égalité quand même
j'y crois aussi en l'égalité mais je
veux à mon tour affirmer que
l'universalisme et le seul cas possible
pour tendre vers effective pour
reconnaître les injustices et réparer
cette légèreté avec laquelle certaines
personnalités s'en prennent à l'héritage
des lumières celui qui permet
l'évancipation est à la fois
déconcertante et dangereuse surtout
quand les droits de l'homme sont un peu
partout contestés l'universalisme est un
projet ambitieux en construction
perpétuelle il serait désiré des
raisonnable pardon de l'incriminé au
prétexte des insuffisances démocratiques
le seul vrai danger serait de critiquer
que seuls des noirs peuvent défendre des
noirs que seuls des musulmans peuvent
défendre des musulmans et ainsi de suite
ce n'est pas ce qu'a dit mais c'est la
pente sur laquelle nous mène sa critique
sans universalisme point d'issue
collective point de communauté nationale
ou alors on accepte une société où l'on
vit séparément où chacun protège ses
petits intérêts dans son petit coin je
n'en veux pas et vous non plus je
l'espère c'est dit et on entend bien
voilà le l'avocat que vous êtes et vous
avez pris la défense de cet Universalis
merci beaucoup merci pour ce parti pris
Mario Stasi président de la lycra alors
il reste deux minutes parce que vous
avez mordu sur le temps Mario Chloé pour
nous parler de ce qui s'est passé à
Davos le secrétaire général des Nations
unies qui a poussé un véritable coup de
gueule contre les Géants du pétrole ou
plutôt contre leur sinisme absolument
Antonio Guterres donc le secrétaire
général de l'ONU a dénoncé un grand
mensonge ce mensonge c'est celui des
géants pétroliers sur le réchauffement
climatique Antonio Guterres a déclaré je
cite que certains producteurs d'énergie
fossiles étaient parfaitement conscients
dès les années 70 que leurs produits
allaient faire brûler la planète mais
comme l'industrie du tabac ils ont fait
peu de cas de leur propre science
certains géants de pétroliers ont
colporté le grand mensonge on sait en
effet que depuis les années 70 des
géants pétroliers comme Total ou exson
mobile disposer d'études précises qui
montrait que les énergies fossiles
entraînerait un réchauffement climatique
tel qu'il remettrait en cause les
conditions de vie sur terre et ces
entreprises ont non seulement choisi
d'ignorer cette science mais aussi de la
nier en semant le doute en disposant de
fausses informations au nom de leur seul
intérêt financier résultat les énergies
fossiles représentent encore aujourd'hui
80% des énergies et ces entreprises là
elles ont une responsabilité devant
l'histoire et devant les générations
dont la mienne qu'ils feront souffrir
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'il
faut traduire ces responsables-là devant
la justice c'est ce que propose le
secrétaire général de l'ONU et moi je
pense qu'il a raison ces entreprises là
elles doivent payer comme par exemple
l'industrie du tabac avait dû verser à
46 États américains 256 milliards de
dollars pour être précises pour soigner
d'anciens fumeurs nous aujourd'hui nous
devons soigner notre planète et la dette
est énorme nous en payons le prix dans
notre corps dans notre santé mais aussi
dans notre porte-monnaie puisque ce sont
des centaines de milliers de milliards
de dollars qu'il va falloir débourser
pour s'adapter au réchauffement
climatique que ces entreprises ont
notamment engendré et construit un monde
soutenable donc ces entreprises doivent
payer et j'irai plus loin elles doivent
être mis sous tutelle démocratique au
nom de l'ordre public parce pense que
les enjeux sont trop graves pour qu'on
laisse à quelques patrons et à leurs
actionnaires le choix de décider pour
l'avenir de l'humanité selon le groupe
d'experts de l'ONU pour le climat le
fameux GIEC il faudrait arrêter tout
nouveau projet d'énergie fossile dès
maintenant or vous avez des entreprises
comme Total qui continuent leur
expansion et qui continue d'ouvrir de
nouveaux projets comme en Afrique avec
le fameux projet Yacob qui est une
petite Annette que pipeline de pétrole
chauffée alors une petite relance très
rapidement à l'heure des charges ces
entreprises elles répondent à une
demande et la demande de pétrole elle a
répondu à une demande de pétrole
effectivement et c'est vrai que les
États portent une lourde responsabilité
pour avoir accompagné la construction
d'un monde où on dépend des énergies
fossiles pour se déplacer se chauffer se
nourrir mais en asséchant les énergies
fossiles cela renforcera aussi
l'incitation à s'en débarrasser et
surtout les entreprises ne font pas que
répondre à une demande bien souvent
aussi elle l'a créé et les entreprises
il faut le rappeler doivent servir le
bien commun avant tout avant la
recherche du profit et pour ça il faut
les tenir responsables il faut les
soumettre à la décision démocratique il
faut transformer leur gouvernance il ne
faut pas les laisser définir besoin et
il faut le répéter encore encore et
encore l'irresponsabilité
l'irresponsabilité des entreprises tu et
ben voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle deux
parties pris bien tranchées bien campés
comme on les aime merci les affranchis
vous partez bien votre nom la mise sous
tutelle démocratique je retiens cette
expression et merci à vous deux d'être
venu sur le plateau de LCP à très vite
elles amont d'un GABA pas de temps pour
réagir malheureusement à demain très
belle soirée documentaire avec
Jean-Pierre Gratien à demain bien sûr
même mieux même heure
[Musique]